in the past six hours have you is it
become any clearer about this bachelor
wedding
oh the bachelor wedding the marriage
it's I wouldn't say it's a wedding but
there there's a possible marriage
between Kaylin and Dean and to be honest
it's been something we've been
speculating about for the past six weeks
not even six hours because we shot that
video where there is that big release
every just every time we asked Dean or
Kaylin about it they're like yeah we're
married and they say like that them
right now more info no we were with them
all weekend long and they still are
joking that are joking that they are
married like when we met them up for
dinner later on Saturday they go we
spent the day looking at engagement
rings for Kaylin he's like cuz I already
have my wedding band we have no idea I
feel bad Todd because we're in texted
I'm wary attacks him today because we
were on the phone with Zima and we were
talking we were like okay we're on the
phone even what's going on he's like
nothing do you think I just I am very
surprised because to me it Dean did not
seem like a settle down guy at all even
when he was on The Bachelorette I was
like this guy's not looking for a wife
that's I don't know if I'm guessing
maybe that's what's going on maybe he's
wearing the wedding band because he
really wants to show Kaylin that he's
committed and they may have like talked
about possibly looking at rings for
Kaylin so like who the hell knows on my
podcast the almost famous podcast this
week he says that Catelynn his
relationship with Kailyn has been the
first time in a long time and he's
considered marriage a possibility in his
life you could say you can see just
knowing Dean and seeing him with you
know not a lot of women obviously but
like seeing he's had a lot of on-screen
relationships he just is really I think
he's in love with Kailyn I do I think
he's in love with it and that's great
cuz we love her too so awesome portant
Lee I have more questions
Peter says that he's in love with three
people
he said it going into fantasy suites
he's in love with three people that's
not possible
that's the producers telling him what to
say or just him getting lost in the
moment I think he's infatuated with
three people I think if you go ask him
now because that was recorded in
November it'd be a go ask him now I bet
you he'll say he was only in love with
one person for real yeah is he really in
love with Victoria F after how that
whole thing went down he's in love with
her I see him being more in love with
Victoria after than Hannah than Hannah
and right now because it's just such a
frenzy that he has such an obsession
compulsion I have a question what do you
make or what is the secret to making a
relationship work when it's not your
time on the show anymore I mean like
well they're you everyone go through
cycles but you're like the person
everyone's talking about there you're
the you know whoever the Peter or
whatever it is like you guys now
obviously that's how you became to be
known but now you're out of it like
you're still in the nation but you're
not on the TV every week doing it like
what is this house how do you stay
successful in your relationship I mean
treating it like just that a
relationship I think like you said a lot
of people they get caught up in the
moment and they're together
and they know that they're stronger
together than apart and like all these
people care about your relationship and
there's this hi and then of course that
goes away because just like anything
else like we got married and everybody
was like oh my god that's incredible
and then like September came and was
like yeah you guys are a married couple
like congratulations okay well entertain
us with babies okay we we we care about
you when you get engaged when you get
married and then when you have babies
with those intermediate times but that's
legit just like every relationship like
every couple out there goes through that
those ups and downs and so just to make
sure that you know that this is gonna
get very real for you and to understand
that and accept that I think is a big
part of making a bachelor relationship
work outside the show
[Music]